Let's build a better tool.
Here I built a function called "timedcalls" with the plural s rather than a single timedcall,
and it takes a number N, saying repeat this timing N times.
Then it takes the function and the arguments to apply to.
It builds up a list of the timed calls.
It throws away the results and just takes the time.
Then it returns three values, the minimum of the times,
the average of the times, and the maximum of the times.
From those you can do whatever statistical analysis you want to do in order
to get a better feeling for what the timing is like.
Now, if the function runs very quickly--
say, if the function took 100th of a second
then you might want to give an N of 1000 or so.
If the function takes about a second to run, maybe you don't want to wait that long
or maybe you want to give a smaller value of N.
Part of the problem is if you have a good idea how long the function takes,
then you can be precise about what a good value of N is.
If you don't, you don't know.
I'm going to propose a different version of timedcalls.
This version has the same signature as the three inputs
and returns the min, average, and max,
but this time it treats N two different ways.
What we're going to do is say if N is an integer, then do the same thing we did before,
but if N is a floating point number, then what we want to do is keep on
repeatedly call timedcalls for the number of trials it takes until we've
added up to that number of seconds.
If N is equal to the integer 10, we repeat 10 timedcalls.
If N is equal to the floating point number 10.0,
then we repeat it until 10.0 seconds have elapsed.
Here is a hint. We can ask if N is an integer and then do one thing.
If N is not an integer, then to the other. See if you can fill in that code.